[Music]
so
throughout the course of the military
history of all nations
epidemics of jaundice have occurred
the revolutionary war the civil war
the franco-prussian war the boer war
in world war one in world war ii
in all armies east and west throughout
the world
research in world war ii developed for
the first time
an understanding of the epidemiology of
viral hepatitis
viral hepatitis is a generalized
infection
involving the entire body but producing
its outstanding manifestations
by damaging the liver
the infecting virus has two forms i
h and sh
the ih virus causes epidemic hepatitis
epidemic hepatitis has a seasonal
distribution
in civil life epidemic hepatitis is more
common in the younger age groups
especially between the ages of 8 and 14.
in the armed forces it is also more
common in the younger age groups
both the ih and the sh virus may cause
homologous serum hepatitis
the sh virus is the more common
ideologic agent
infection is due to the presence of
these viruses
in needles and syringes
and blood products
there is no seasonal variation
periods of increased use of blood and
blood products
cause peaks of incidence
the two viruses cause essentially the
same clinical and pathologic pictures
with one major
difference the length of the incubation
period
for the ih virus it is 15 to 35 days to
the appearance of jaundice
and for the sh virus 50 to 140 days to
the appearance of jaundice
active infection with either ih or sh
virus seems to produce immunity to that
particular virus
cross immunity does not exist previous
infection with ih virus will not prevent
a later
sh infection
conversely previous sh infection will
not prevent ih infection
transmission of the disease occurs from
both active cases
and asymptomatic carriers only blood and
feces
have been proved infectious
no insect vector or animal host has been
found
that will maintain or pass the virus
the possibility of transmission by other
means cannot be excluded
species may contain the ih virus
fecal contamination of the water supply
is not controlled by routine
chemical water purification
poor personal hygiene and troops
especially in
food handlers may lead to food-borne
epidemics
blood may contain either the ih or the
sh virus
homologous serum hepatitis results from
the use of virus contaminated blood and
equipment
as little as 1 100 of a cc of blood or
tissue fluid
may contaminate a syringe
inadequate sterilization of syringes and
other instruments
or the use of the multiple dose syringe
will spread the virus
contaminated blood rarely comes from
jaundice donors
but rather from asymptomatic carriers
the incidence of infection from whole
blood is less than one percent
because of pooling of plasma from many
donors during processing
the incidence of infection from plasma
is 7 to 20 percent
during world war ii several hundred
thousand cases of viral hepatitis were
reported
a classical picture is now recognized
the most common early symptom is
anorexia
inflammation in both the liver and the
gastrointestinal tract
may explain the abdominal discomfort and
vomiting after meals
headache is often a prominent symptom
mild chills and fever are the rule
there is often a definite photophobia
the first specific sign of liver damage
is dark urine
due to the presence of bilirubin the
preectaric phase
lasting seven to ten days is followed by
the appearance of scleral and
generalized jaundice
physical examination may show no
jaundice in the prodromal stage of
hepatitis
in some cases it never appears
conjunctivitis is seen in the early
stages
it may be associated with orbital pain
and pain on motion of the eyes
the lymph glands are involved early
in the absence of jaundice the most
reliable sign of hepatitis
is hepatic tenderness either to
palpation
or to fist percussion over the right
lower chest
sometimes hepatic tenderness is the only
definite finding
splenomegaly may be present in early
hepatitis
the non-specific symptoms and signs tend
to disappear shortly after
jaundice appears if the history and
physical findings suggest hepatitis
the patient should be hospitalized
laboratory findings confirm the
diagnosis
the test for bilirubin in the urine is
easily performed
and is frequently the first definite
indication of hepatic abnormality
to confirm the diagnosis of hepatitis
the thymal turbidity and keflam
cholesterol flocculation tests are
essential
serum bilirubin determinations may be
used to follow the progression
and regression of jaundice
strict bed rest should be instituted at
once and maintained
this may include bathroom privileges for
bowel movements only
therapy should include a well-balanced
high caloric diet
fat restriction is not indicated in
hepatitis
if food intake is satisfactory dietary
supplements such as choline or
methionine are not necessary
vitamins may be given
bed rest should be maintained for at
least four weeks
or until the serum bilirubin falls to
normal
after the serum bilirubin reaches normal
gradual ambulation of the patient is
started
supervised ambulation should allow not
more than four hours out of bed at the
start
the time is gradually increased in the
second and third weeks
if ambulation produces clinical or
laboratory evidence of relapse
the patient should be put back to bed
a normal brom-sulfolene dye excretion
test is an important criterion for
return to duty
a period of fairly strenuous
reconditioning may be advisable before
return to judy
the histologic changes of acute
hepatitis have been studied
in biopsy and postmortem material here
is a diagram of a normal liver cord and
portal area
in acute hepatitis one of the earliest
findings is a diffuse
cellular infiltration
there may be marked cellular necrosis
and condensation of the hepatic
parenchyma
the clinical severity of the disease may
not parallel the histologic severity
necrosis is followed by cell
regeneration
nuclear changes and variations in cell
size and staining occur
early and may persist after clinical
recovery
viral hepatitis may occur with or
without jaundice
hepatitis with jaundice may be confused
with
obstructive jaundice
hemolytic jaundice
infectious mononucleosis
cirrhosis
metastatic carcinoma in the liver
toxic hepatitis wiles disease
and amoebic hepatitis these diseases
must be ruled out
from a practical point of view the most
common problem in differential diagnosis
is the exclusion of obstructive jaundice
this is most commonly caused by an
impacted gallstone
in the common bile duct
many other lesions may produce
obstructive jaundice for example
carcinoma of the head of the pancreas
obstructive jaundice is ruled out by
history
positive flocculation and turbidity
tests normal
or borderline alkaline phosphatase
negative
x-ray findings and liver biopsy
excessive breakdown of red blood cells
causes anemia and jaundice
hemolytic jaundice is ruled out by lack
of anemia
normal tests for hemolysis the presence
of bile in the urine
and normal fecal urobilinogen
infectious mononucleosis with jaundice
has many features in common with viral
hepatitis
infectious mononucleosis is ruled out by
a normal
heterophyll antibody titer
an episode of hepatic failure in
cirrhosis of the liver may resemble
acute hepatitis
cirrhosis may be ruled out by the lack
of a history of alcoholism or
malnutrition
but liver biopsy may be the only means
of making this distinction
metastatic carcinoma within the liver
may produce jaundice
this is ruled out by the lack of a
primary lesion in by liver biopsy
toxic hepatitis may be produced by
various chemicals especially carbon
tetrachloride
it may be ruled out when there is no
history of exposure
and the flocculation and turbidity tests
are markedly positive
leptospiral infections may cause
jaundice
but are ruled out by the absence of
leptospira in blood or urine
jaundice may be present in amabiasis of
the liver
amoebic hepatitis is ruled out when a
media are absent
or when there is no response to specific
treatment
in summary each of these diseases has
differentiating characteristics which
permit its exclusion
hepatitis without jaundice because of
its systemic
and gastrointestinal manifestations must
be considered in the diagnosis of many
conditions of acute onset
the systemic manifestations include
chills
fever malaise and headache
the gastrointestinal manifestations are
anorexia
nausea vomiting diarrhea and abdominal
pain
in a patient with any of these symptoms
hepatitis should be considered
an enlarged tender liver and positive
liver function test
establish the diagnosis of hepatitis
without jaundice
the importance of the disease to the
army lies in the duration of the illness
the average case is disabled for 12
weeks
attempts to hasten this process may
result in acute relapse
this is frequently caused by premature
overactivity
ingestion of alcohol and in some cases
the cause of the relapse remains unknown
hepatitis persisting more than six
months is considered
chronic hepatitis cases of chronic
hepatitis
often have a history of inadequate
treatment during the acute phase
the most common symptoms are anorexia
weakness easy fatigue ability and upper
abdominal discomfort physical signs may
include an enlarged tender liver
splenomegaly and spider nevi
liver function tests may be positive
liver biopsy is necessary to establish
the diagnosis
the histologic picture is that of
continuing inflammatory and regenerative
changes
in a few cases the appearance of bile
duct proliferation
and fibrosis suggests the development of
cirrhosis
the treatment of chronic hepatitis is
discouraging
it involves prolonged periods of bed
rest continued dietary therapy
and abstinence from alcohol there is
indication that oreomycin is beneficial
in some cases
many cases of chronic hepatitis will
recover eventually
the outcome in others is unknown
the prognosis of acute hepatitis is good
only a fraction of one percent of
patients die during the acute stage
about two percent have persistent
chronic hepatitis at the end of a year
the rest recover completely
viral hepatitis is a common disease in
the army
diagnosis is seldom difficult if the
possibility is considered
the disease is self-limited the course
is prolonged
there is no specific treatment bed rest
must be maintained until evidence of
active disease has subsided
strict adherence to this regimen will
decrease the incidence of acute relapse
and the development of chronic hepatitis
you